so i wanted to ask you douglas about the
the media in britain versus the media in
the united states because
you've written pretty extensively about
the differences between media in in both
countries it's it's sort of fascinating
the united states
obviously we have very broad free speech
rules much broader than the the free
speech rules in in britain but at the
same time
our media seemed to be significantly
more sensorious significantly
uh more welcoming to
toward opinions masquerading as
objective
journalism can you give us sort of a
rundown on on the differences between
british media and
american media in this way yeah i mean
the um
whenever i'm in america and absorb a lot
of american media it makes me
um value the bbc um
uh which i you know have plenty of
criticisms of
um but i do think that there have been
several things that have happened in
america
american media in recent years which
have been very much the negative i mean
i think the main thing is
we don't really have the sort of
creations you have
there of people who
are for instance in front of the camera
and expected
to explain a world view for a willing
waiting
um you know our news
programs in particular mainly because of
impartiality rules you have you have to
sort of demonstrate impartiality which
is you know something
but it's there as an aspiration should
we say
um in british broadcasting you can't
just
go on air and as a presenter say stuff
um uh you have to counter balance and
much more now of course there's a
problem with that
the problem of the of the balance issue
in british
broadcasting is when you have
and it does happen you have somebody i
don't know for instance uh
it happens a lot on the the israel one
you know you get
you get somebody from you know who's a
sort of moderate leftist
analyst of israeli affairs and because
they recognize
you know the israeli government you have
to balance them out with you know
abu jihad uh uh uh from the years you
know the al-aqsa martyrs brigade
uh you know and and so there's this
weird idea that
that that's the that's the balance of
the debate
and and i'm afraid that does happen on
quite a lot of things
and it it it it negatively uh
impacts our understanding of a range of
issues so there is a problem to this
balance
uh thing but it does save us
from you know having
what i saw recently uh uh um don lemon
starting a show by just saying you know
it's and he named the i think it was
after the
whole country's comment to president
trump you know don lemon goes on
he says you know uh uh it's whatever the
date is and the president of the united
states is a racist
like you just couldn't you couldn't do
that in british broadcasting you can't
just
you can't just go on air as a presenter
and say stuff
um and i think that has had a hugely
negative effect in america and i think
the worst thing by the way
is the is this thing of two sides that
talk about each other and never to each
other
you know that the left says you know the
thing about conservatives is and
the right says the thing about the left
is and
i just think it all it'll make things a
a lot worse
as my own opinion but i mean i've had
this experience personally actually
obviously
uh being from america and dealing almost
solely with american media when i was on
bbc with andrew neal and i had no clue
who he was and he was just playing
devil's advocate with me
or taking a skeptical point of view i
had no understanding that that's
actually
his job is to basically just play the
other side to whomever
he's interviewing and so my core
assumption was okay if somebody is going
to be speaking to me that way then it's
because they are representing
their actual viewpoint which is the way
that it works in the united states yes
i i had that quite early on in my uh
news night once for the legendary
broadcaster called jeremy paxman
jeremy paxman asked me a question i i
did you know i sort of finally and he
seemed
like what i said and i i sort of and i
was feeling well
smug and he laid into the other guy and
i was actually making the mistake of
sort of sitting there
vaguely smiling and jeremy paxton
wheeled around to me so i said what are
you smiling at and
and then attacked me on something and i
thought it was a it was a good uh lesson
early on that you know the presenter is
just never on your side in british tv
so with that said let's turn to british
politics in the media treatment of boris
johnson so obviously in the united
states the media treatment of president
trump is 107
negative uh there has yet to be a
broadcaster in los angel in uh in
the united states outside of fox news uh
who voted for president trump who even
thinks that president trump is a
is a breathing sentient human being as
opposed to just a bad orange
giant with with minimal hand size so
how has the media treatment been of
boris johnson in britain
there is some similarity um in in the
treatment
there has been an attempt to um pretend
that you know boris johnson is some
appalling divisive figure and
and so for so on it doesn't actually
work
i have to say one of the reasons is that
actually in conservative terms
boris johnson is very liberal uh and i
mean this in in a way in
in the american and the british sense of
the understanding of that term
um his instincts are deeply liberal in
the
in the true classical sense and um
he's certainly not some authoritarian
figure
um he was enormously
successful by being elected twice as the
mayor of london
in a labor voting city he twice took
that position for the conservative party
um so he's obviously able to attract
crossover votes
uh by leading the brexit campaign the
leave campaign in 2016
and that being successful a lot of
people who did like him or had time for
him
definitely turned against him uh he
definitely took the brunt for a long
time with the
negative fallout that did come from
people who were furious
about the brexit vote uh but by and
large i would say that he enjoys
um um some some better uh
better press in the in the uk certainly
the president trump does in the u.s
and i think there's there's lots of
reasons for that but one of them is just
the fact that
the separating saw that we've had under
british politics in recent years
has been addressed now i mean i was very
very worried for my country in recent
years
much as i have been from america in this
era because it
did seem to me that having voted having
voted to leave
eu in 2016 we had such pushback
all the same things that were done in
the u.s after the trump vote you know
the voters are racist the voters are
sexist the voters are misogynists the
voters are homophobic they are
voting for an increase in hate crime
they're carrying out hate crimes
and much more we had all of that before
it was done in the states as this
massive playback
to punish the voters uh and and we we
i worried that that era was not going to
end by actually
taking control of the conservative party
finally and leading the uk
out of the eu it seems to me that that
terrible saw
has finally been lanced and that
it's meant that although there are some
people who just want to replay 2016
forever by and large
people have now progressed through the
various stages of grief
and but while there were people who were
stuck
on the second or third stage you know
they were still bargaining they were
still pleading
i know the people voted to leave eu but
perhaps we can
uh beg them not to or get it back or
by and large those people have passed
through the stages of grief now and
and have realized that we've got to make
the best job of where we are
whether you were for leaving or or for
remain
and so so so in a better position on
that and i just had one thing which is
that throughout this corona virus
it is striking to me that there has been
much more um
public support and unanimity for the
government's
stance here because it's boris johnson i
mean i can assure you as a
fairly vocal critic of jeremy corbyn who
was the labour party leader until
earlier this year
if jeremy corbyn had won the election in
december and jeremy corbyn and diane
abbott his
would have been his home secretary had
told me to confine myself to my house
and never leave again
i'm not sure i'd have i'd have agreed to
do it
i'd be very suspicious of it um i just
thought it was very personal apart from
anything else
um but no i i i don't think that is i
think there's reason why we have a
certain amount of trust in boris johnson
in a way that
that that in america you know as i say
just have this totally bifurcated still
uh nation still so i touched on a little
bit earlier but i was wondering if maybe
you could explicate for for folks in the
united states
who are on the right side of the aisle
the difference is between sort of
british conservatism and american
conservatism and american conservatism
there's been this real drive for
smaller government a more libertarian
view of society
uh in in british conservatism what are
the animating forces behind british
conservatism that separate them on the
one hand from sort of the labor party
and on the other hand from american
conservatives
the truth is is that in in many ways uh
british conservatives would be seen as
pretty left-wing by the american
counterparts
and i've seen it all my life i mean
there is a very clear difference in
drive between the republican party for
instance in the us
and the conservative party in the uk um
part of it is tonal part of it
goes back to that thing i mentioned at
the beginning of you know the
conservative party having for a long
time made its peace
with the welfare state um and
i i i think beyond that there's a very
interesting
question within british conservatism
which is
is there much more than the economic
uh element of it and and that's
something which
i i think in the states in the states
you could say yes uh
and it's essentially the defense the
amendments and of the constitution
and and some social issues which you
obviously like abortion
go round and round and fight very very
hard on
in a way which i sort of in a way i'd i
admire i admire the fact that america
still takes certain very fundamental
issues very seriously in debates
sincerely but
in in the uk we don't have those sorts
of issues you don't really have
uh um these litmus test
issues i think that's i think that
that's a failure in many ways
and i've often um had this conversation
with
other conservatives and conservative
philosophers in the uk of what
conservative thinking in the uk
really is um because it has been hard in
recent decades to identify what it is
beyond a certain view of um
the state a certain view of um
of the economy i'd say this is this is a
um
something that needs to be addressed
because conservatives
took conservatives took an awful lot for
granted in the uk
um and and probably have been reminded
all of us in our lifetimes of how unwise
that is let me give an example i mean
we have a monarchy in the uk um and
uh this is just part of the fabric of
the state now
i would say that it's obvious that the
conservative would inevitably be
defensive of the monarchy
inevitably be in favor of the monarchy
but it isn't something you hear
people going on about um because it's
sort of agreed upon it's accepted uh um
there are some people who you know want
to get rid of the monarchy but
my point is is that we have great
institutions in the uk
wonderful institutions which have
endured the test of time
um and have provided as the queen has
actually in particular in recent weeks
extraordinary level of of of
uh unity and and really moral
encouragement to the country
um but i mentioned that because
conservatives don't go
on about it because it's just in the
fabric of the nation
and many of these institutions many
things that are conservative we've just
forgotten to talk about and
and you know i mentioned roger scrutin
earlier it was a great friend and
a great inspiration to me and um roger
was always thinking about this
why is it that conservatives have so
little to say about for instance beauty
the built environment you know what does
it matter if you've got a conservative
government in power
if it's wrecked the inner cities of all
of our beautiful cities
and put up horrible horrible monstrosity
buildings
you know i think it was lord clark uh um
and clark's father um
kenneth clark law clerk of civilization
uh who said
that if if you want to judge a
civilization
um you shouldn't you shouldn't read the
speeches of the finance minister
you should look at what buildings
they've directed that'll tell you
that'll tell you everything very very
fast
and and i do think that there's
something in that what did it matter to
have post-war conservative governments
erecting huge tower blocks that they
expected the populist to live in
um so there are an awful lot of
questions which
which we've just presumed and a lot of a
lot of these presumptions have just been
been allowed to go by by conservatives
in the belief that well at least we've
got control of the economy
and and that that that is um that is
something i think which everybody on the
right has to think about
more is is and
mainly sorry i'm going on it but let me
just say one thing mainly because
it's so striking to me that the left
speaks at a totally different level from
the right on issue after issue
again this may not be the case quite so
much in the us but
i'm just so struck by the fact that the
left does something like
inequality and the right talks about a
small increase in house building in
brownfield site areas or something it's
like wow that's going to fire them up
and and again and again on issue after
issue that's what happens you know
the left talks to things that are very
deep
uh are you often used to talk about this
with roger with look at
look at resentment and look at
resentment
envy those are deep
deep human instincts to play to and when
the left does resentment and envy
if the right just says oh we found this
really interesting tax loophole that we
can address
it's not that you're not doing anything
but you are not acting at the same level
if somebody does resentment to you you
need to do something of
equal weight back i would argue on that
one aspiration for instance
but you need to if somebody else is
talking about despair you need to talk
about hope you know
you need to counter these out
and i think we haven't done actually
conservatism in the uk has been in power
but has done a horrible job
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel
so you don't miss out on any of our
content